congratulations you've recently had your
second child I have yeah that is I had
the experience of having one child and
thinking ìokay I can see what this is
and then we had a second child and it
doesn't just get twice as hard right no
no no it's exponentially more difficult
it doesn't it doesn't double the work it
like quadruples
the work for some reason I don't
understand that it's like you just
you're constantly you know you're like
cooking dinner over here trying to keep
somebody from killing themselves over
there while you're like painting your
nails at the same time because you got
to have nice toes yes I had that
problems young one I'm curious it's a
boy and a girl right yeah now do they
get along dude they're really sweet my
son is he's 3 and he's a little bit
bigger and boys just have that energy
and he knocks her over constantly giving
her really big hugs right which is very
a sweet problem to have but he does know
how strong he is yes and what about do
they ask embarrassing questions yet
because sometimes when there's a boy and
a girl they ask embarrassing no he does
he's very fascinated by how different
she is then he is in the obvious ways of
course we know we stick him in the bath
together because that's just easier he
was asking the other day why she has a
front butt and I just decided it was
better to let him have that one until
he's about 18 yeah he'll figure it out
no one explained that to me till I was
in my 30s
you